hello and welcome to the
third part of my tutorial about logic
and computer science with a strong bias
towards
automata in this part i will be talking
about a variant of the model checking
problem
where we fix a formula and the algorithm
inputs
model and tells you if the formula is
true
i will mainly focus on modules which are
graphs but
the general models will follow the same
will follow the same
idea the motivation behind
such model checking problems is that
many classical algorithmic problems can
be
just formalized using logical formulas
well
in a certain sense all of them because
logic is the language of mathematics
but the formalization uses simple logic
such as first order logic in many cases
let's have a look at some examples
i will begin with problems algorithmic
problems that can be formalized just in
first order logic using the
graph structure alone such as the edges
so consider for example the clique
problem
where we fix a size of the clique and we
are asking
if our graph contains a clique of size k
this can be easily written down in first
or logic just by writing down the
definition
of a clique just say that there exists k
edges which are pairwise connected by
edge
by edges another example is a vertex
cover of size k
you want to know if there exists a k
vertices such that every edge has at
least one of its
end points among these k edges
so in in these particular examples i
fixed a
k and then i for each decay i wrote a
different formula
later on when i will move on to a more
powerful logic namely monadic second
order logic i will
i will be allowed to skip the write a
uniform formula which does not depend on
k
but even if for if when the formula
depends on k
there are interesting things to be said
so you could ask the following question
maybe for first or every first order
sentence there is a linear time
algorithm which
recognizes graphical phi is true now the
linear time algorithm is
is is supposed to be linear in the graph
but
since the form of sentence is fixed then
the multiplicative constant in the
linear time
could be exponential in phi or it could
be ackermann or something
maybe let's just say it has to be
computable now
uh there is an obvious polynomial time
algorithm for every first order sentence
uh
you just evaluate it so you you go you
replace the quantifiers by for loops
but the number of nested for loops is
the nesting of the quantifiers
and therefore the degree of the
polynomial time depends on the formula
phi
but the question is can you drop this
degree
to say linear or maybe quadratic but
a degree which is independent of the
formula phi
possibly at the cost of having a large
multiplicative constant
now there are some promising uh
examples so if you look at the vertex
cover of size k
although it has well k plus two
quantifiers
you can actually solve it in a linear
time
without having a polynomial that loops
through all possible k plus 2 tuples
and it is a classical uh
algorithm in in a field called fixed
parameter attractability i will i will
not go over it
the running time is exponential in the
size of the a hypothetical vertex cover
but it is linear
in the size of the graph and this is an
example of a fixed parameter tractable
algorithm
where you have this parameter k you're
allowed to behave exponentially or worse
in the parameter
but in the main in the input size which
is here the graph size you're supposed
to be linear
or maybe quadratic but in a way
polynomial that does not depend
on the parameter okay so uh maybe
our hypothetical linear time
algorithm for every formula phi does
exist
well the click problem seems to be a
hard
instance so it is in the field of fixed
parameter tractability it is conjectured
but you cannot
solve the clique in what is known as
fixed parameter retractable time
which means there is no algorithm which
runs in a
time polynomial in the graph size with
multiplied by some
computable function of the size of the
click that you're searching for and
therefore since a click
cannot be uh can click can be defined in
first or the logic this conjecture says
that there is no uh that would imply
that there is no linear time algorithm
that recognizes
uh if every first order formula well
for there is no it is not the case that
for every formula there is a linear time
argument or a quadratic one for that
matter
but nonetheless uh since you can express
uh many things in first order logic it's
interesting to search
for for maybe special cases where you
can find the near time algorithm
another logic that we can consider and
and then this is the one that
has been uh receiving much attention in
my tutorial so far is monadic second
order logic
in monadic second order logic you can
express
more obviously more problems for example
a three color a bit
so you just write out the definition of
recolorability in monadic second order
logic you say
uh there exists three sets of vertices i
won't write the quantifiers because i'll
probably make a mistake
such that well you just write out the
definition recolorability so no edge has
both end points in the same set
and every vertex belongs to some set
and and and therefore uh you have here
a sentence of monadic second order logic
such that the graphs which satisfied
form an
np-complete set and if you if you think
about
monadic second-order logic then
the the obvious algorithm for it
is in the polynomial time hierarchy uh
if it has alternate
alternates end times between existential
and universal set quantifiers you would
expect it to be
on the end level of the polynomial
hierarchy and and nothing
better is is known
another example is a hamiltonian so
you can write just again the definition
of the hamiltonian path
as follows you say there exists a set of
edges
now this is i wanted to to to highlight
this
to to point to the fact that it is
important how you model a graph
i i here i use the model which would
have used in the previous
lecture where the underlying set
of the structure contains both vertices
and edges
and there is an incidence relation and
if you use this model
then you are allowed to quantify over
sets of edges so you can say there
exists a set of edges
f such that every vertex is incident to
exactly two
edges from the set and then you need to
say that
this set forms a cycle in the sense that
it is a connected
which you can express as follows you say
that you cannot
find a proper subset
which is a loop so so for every
proper subset some vertex is incident to
exactly one head from the proper subset
so you have to cut
the cycle in some place and in fact if
you use
the model for graphs where the
underlying set is vertices and there's a
binary
relation for edges then you could not
define hamiltonian
cycles because uh well this can be
proved so
it is an important distinction so uh
and then you can in monadic second order
logic
you can really define lots and lots of
classical
algorithmic problems and therefore
it is interesting to ask is there maybe
some generic
algorithm which evaluates every proper
formula of logic
on on models and uh well
as i mentioned for click it it is
it is going to be a rather hard but
there exists important results which say
that this can be done
if you limit the kind of graphs that you
are looking at
so here's a nice example which is a
simple
and i will discuss it in more detail
later it says that
you can do linear time model checking of
first order logic for graphs of bounded
degree
so it says that if you fix a first order
sentence
and you fix it bound on the maximal
degree in a graph
having fixed those things you input a
graph and you check if the sentence is
true
in the graph but assuming that the graph
has said the the
boundary on the degree then you can
solve this problem
in linear time uh now i will give you a
a proof later on i just like to
underline the fact that
the algorithm is linear in terms of the
graph but
the constants are well exponential in
the degree
and uh worse than exponential in in in
the sentence of first order logic to
to be looked at a corollary of this is
that since you can formalize the
k clique problem or the vertex cover
problem
in first order logic once k is fixed it
follows that for every
k and d fixed k and d there is a linear
time algorithm
which attacks k click or a k vertex
cover on graphs of degree at most d
another example and this is a the
original
gangster of the series is corsair's
theorem which says that
for every sentence fixed sentence of
magnetic second order logic
and every parameter k the
model checking problem for mso can be
solved in linear time
on graphs of tree with at most k
so so this means that if you fix a bound
on the tree width
then you can check say linear
hamiltonian path for three color ability
or any other problem
formalizable magnetic secondary logic in
the near time
now note that every graph has sum to its
okay so in a sense you have
a family of linear time algorithms which
covers all
graphs however of course the
coefficients in these algorithms are
quite bad and if if you want to
check say a hamiltonian path on a very
large
graph it is not going to be a good idea
to
use the linear time algorithm for the
parameter k which is the graph size
because the
the the algorithm will be linear in the
size of the graph but
far from linear in in the parameter k
and the results such as these two
theorems are called
algorithmic metatheorems because what
they tell you
is that they give you one big hammer
which allows you
to solve any kind of
algorithmic problem that can be stated
in logic uh well
on on on on on on inputs which satisfy
the constraints
the in the theorem so in says this
theorem is going to be
uh graphs of bounded degree for
uh first order logic i mean courser's
theorem is going to be graphs of bounded
through it so let me begin maybe with a
a a more detailed look at crucial
theorem so
you're going to get crusades theorem
immediately from the following two
results
the first one is a theorem of a
bodelander
which tells you that you can compute 3d
compositions in linear time
so it says that for every fixed k
you can solve in linear time the
following problem you're given a graph
and then you uh check if it if there is
a
com 3d composition of which k and if
there is you uh
output such a 3d composition the the 3d
composition is not unique so you output
some
3d composition uh this is a a rather
hard algorithm and i will not have time
to explain
in detail how it works i just like to
point out that there is a
is a prior algorithm in the graph minors
project of robertson and seymour
which is easier to understand it would
take i don't know like
50 minutes or something to explain it
which is a little bit
worse than on the bottle under algorithm
because it is cubic
it doesn't compute a 3d composition of
optimal width but
uh of of of polynomial
bigger width but it is good enough uh to
prove a variant
of corsair's theorem where instead of a
linear time you have a
cubic time so as i said i won't be going
into a bottlenecker's algorithm
uh which would use the
the the structure or theory of graphs
but i will concentrate on on the logical
part of it
uh which allows us to infer crusades
here
and the logical part is kind of simple
and you've seen it in a a
in some form before but that explains in
more detail now
it says that for every a
fixed bound on three with an msl
sentence you can do the following thing
in linear time you're given not just the
graph
but you're given the tree decomposition
which is a tree and then you want to
know if the underlying
graph of the 3d composition satisfies a
formula phi
now you can easily see that bodelander's
theorem and this lemma
give corsair's theorem because well you
just compute the 3d composition you're
doing botlander's theorem and then you
check
using the lemma if the underlying graph
satisfies the
formula phi so let's have a look at at
the left
why is it true well if you remember
from the previous lectures i mentioned
that you can pull back
uh an mso formula from graphs uh
to uh 3d compositions so
the result the the dilemma that
observation is
that for every k uh you can if you have
a formula
the black phi which runs on the graph so
it has access to
vertices and edges on the incidence
relation
then in a graph then you can
put it back to a formula red phi which
works directly on
three decompositions of with k so these
are trees
where every node has zero one or two
children
zero for the constant one for the forget
operations and two for the merge
operations
the trees are labeled because every node
is labeled by the operation that it uses
and this formula red phi can uh work
directly in the
in the tree which describes the 3d
compositions and it tells you if the
black phi formula is going to be true in
in the graph and
this is because you can interpret a
graph in its
in its 3d composition so this is an
observation that we made before
and uh once you have that you are not
far away from
evaluating
[Music]
mso in linear time and the reason is
that
all you need to do now is you need to if
you're given the 3d composition you need
to evaluate the red five formula
and it remains to show that every fixed
mso formula
on trees can be evaluated in linear time
so
some some function of the formula which
we're going to be is going to be a
tower of exponentials uh times the size
of the tree so if the formula is fixed
then the evaluation algorithm is linear
and the reason why you can evaluate mso
in linear time on trees
is that you can compile it to automata
so uh this is an old result which
goes back to thatcher and wright in 1968
which says that for finite trees
mso and three automata define the same
languages
so let me maybe explain in more detail
what a three-automaton is
it works as follows so first of all i i
explain what i mean by a tree in more
detail so i i consider trees
which are over ranked alphabet so that
means that the input alphabet
every letter has an arity so for example
the letter a
it has arrow d2 which means every use of
the letter a will have
two children's two children the the
letter b
has a arity one which means that every
use
of letter b will have one child and
finally letter c it has arity 0 which
means it has to be a leaf
and on such trees you can run a
deterministic bottom up automata so this
is one of one variant of tree automata
and the way it works it just assigns
trees
beginning with the leaves and
progressing towards the root and
once you have assigned states to all of
your children and you have label a then
you use a transition function delta sub
a to a compute the new state in
in your node in the special case where a
has arity
zero then uh delta sub a is just a
constant
it tells you what is the state to be
used for uh for
for for leaves with with that particular
labor
and so then you apply this transition
function and you get
a state in every leaf and then you
progress up to three
and eventually you will get a state in
the root and then
you check if it is accepted this is a
deterministic bottom map automaton on
finite trees
so in the first lecture i discussed a
non-deterministic automaton infinite
trees those were far more complicated
but a
deterministic bottom up automata on the
finite trees are quite a simple object
and it is
the one described here and it is uh
rather
easy to see it's it's very similar to
the classical well this is what touch
right prove that language is recognized
by this automata
have all of the prop closure properties
of mso so they're closed under union
which can be sold using a product
construction complementation
since these are deterministic you just
complement the accepting set and
protection so for projection what one
way you can do it is you can introduce
non-deterministic bottom bottom-up tree
automata
and then show that they can be
determinized which they in fact
can be and uh and
therefore we see that mso is containing
trial mata
and mso and throughout the mso in the
same way as for finite words
and in fact the the the proof that this
correspondence is is just the same proof
as for behalf but threatened brought
for finite words but you just have to uh
use three automata
on finite trees as i mentioned before
the raven theorem which came
one one year later 1969 is is a much
more
sophisticated construction uh
since a deterministic bottom up to
automata it can be evaluated in linear
time
then it follows that every mso formula
can be evaluated in linear time
because it is equivalent to some tree
automaton which can which can also be
computed and thus it follows that
there is a linear time algorithm for
evaluating 12
given a 2d composition which is just
around the appropriate tree automaton
and this completes the proof of kusar's
theorem i'd like to point out that
this there's a there's a generalization
there are generalizations of of this
result
to to other tree measures than and then
three with uh
in particular uh rank width which
which is the same notion essentially as
as clique uh which allows you to uh
capture
uh more trees in the sense that uh uh
more three languages have bounded a tree
or ranquet than
bounded through it uh at the cost of of
uh
restricting mso to a variant where you
can only quantify where sets of vertices
but you're not allowed to quantify over
sets
of edges uh the the rank width for
clique source is quite interesting but
and has lots of interesting technical
results there as well
but i have no no no time to talk about
it
in this tutorial so that was crucial's
theorem so we know that
you can on bounded three with you can
evaluate mso a very powerful logic in
linear time and
and therefore for large hundreds of
graph
algorithm graph problems there exist
linear time algorithms for graphs of
boundary trees
now let me have a let's let let's turn
to the census theorem
and let me discuss a little bit how you
can prove it and
what are the kinds of generalizations or
follow-up work
in this journal so in the theorem
the main proof is not going to be
automata we leave
the automata world but it is going to be
something called locality and and
specifically
geithman's a theorem about locality of
first order logic
so let me begin by explaining what this
locality is
uh so here is the gentleman theorem it
says
that every sentence of first order logic
on graphs is equivalent to a boolean
combination of basic local sentences
so what's a basic local sentence it's it
looks like this it says that there
exists k vertices
for some parameter k such that
these vertices are far from each other
so there's another parameter r called
the radius and you
have to say that they're pairwise
distance from each other
and all of these vertices satisfy some
fixed first order property now
it's it's it's it has to be it cannot be
any first order property because
otherwise
you would not be getting anything from
this theorem but it's it's a property
which is
local so what does it mean that the
formula is local
it means that whether or not the formula
is true this is a formula with one free
variables
depends only on a local neighborhood of
the vertex so if you have a graph
then there are neighborhood of a vertex
so here it's like big red vertex
is the the vertices which can be reached
from
the the the the vertex using at most
are edges so here i have a neighborhood
of
radius 2. and a formula is called
r local if it depends only on the r
neighborhood
of the vertex which means there's a
semantic way of of of expressing it
which says
that the formula is true in a vertex if
and only if
it is true in the graph obtained by just
keeping only the r neighborhood and
deleting all the other vertices from the
graph
syntactic characterization which is
equivalent is saying that
a formula is a are local
if it is equivalent to a new formula
where which is obtained by by replacing
every quantifier
in a way that it quantifies only over
vertices which are in
in in our neighborhood of our central
uh vertex and uh this is the syntactic
exchange is easy to see
to be equivalent to the semantic one and
and
this completes the definition of our
local formulas so geifmann's theorem
tells us
that for every first order sentence
you can just evaluate it by looking at
uh
basic local sentences and then there's a
boolean combination of those
a theorem is effective in the sense that
uh given a sentence of first order logic
you can compute
the equivalent combination of basic
local sentences uh although uh the
the boolean combination and the basic
local sentences involved in it are going
to be rather large
in fact non-elementary so towers of
exponentials will be involved
uh so geizmann's locality theorem is
going to be the tool that is going to
will be used in cessna's theorem and its
generalization so as i said
we're not going to be using automata but
locality
so let's prove says this here
thanks to guidance theorem it is enough
to show that we can evaluate in
linear time on graphs of bounded degree
d
sentences which result from guys mass
here kiteman's theorem so basic local
sentences
let us therefore fix a degree bound on
the degree
and a basic local sentence such as the
one on the slide and we will now give a
linear time algorithm for evaluating
it now the main observation is that
since phi of x depends only on
vertices which are around x in a
distance
at most r and the degree of the graph is
bounded
therefore this neighborhood our
neighborhood of every vertex has a
constant size
and we can check if a phi of x in a
constant time
by just running the formula on a
constant size constant size
neighborhood and therefore we can in
linear time we can compute
for every vertex whether or not it
satisfies
phi of x and this will be used to
satisfy the basic local sentence it is
not uh
however all we need
so if k would be one then it would be
fine we would just
search through all vertices and check if
at least one satisfies phi of x
but now what we need to find is k
vertices which are far from each other
and they is each one of them satisfies
phi
so a naive algorithm uh would be uh to
check uh go for every k-2 but that would
have a
be a polynomial of degree k this however
can be solved in linear time
and let me explain the idea just for k
equals two
so uh suppose that the a k is two so
we're searching for two vertices which
are far from each other
and both of them satisfy phi
as i say the naive algorithm is
quadratic for every pair check
if they're they're far away but here's
how you can do it in linear time
so let's do a naive greedy algorithm
first so for
every vertex we we search for the first
vertex which satisfy phi of
x and let's use this as our x1
and uh now we have fixed x1 and then
now we check for all other
vertices for x2 but they have to be far
away from x1 so we set for vertices x2
which are a distance greater than r from
x1 and if we find
one which also satisfies phi then we're
done because we have found
two vertices which is both satisfy phi
and they're a distance greater than r
however this
naive greedy algorithm can give a false
negative
because it could uh be the case that
once you have fixed x1 you will not find
any
x2 which is far away from it and satisfy
phi
but if you would have chosen a different
x1 then you could have
done this so here's a picture suppose
that our greedy algorithm
search for a vertex x1 and the first one
it found was uh
was was this one the one in in red
and then it searches for a another
vertex x2 which is
far away from it and satisfy 5 but it
doesn't find anything so it says no
however if you would have chosen
different vertices namely x1 and x2 in
blue
then these are at the distance uh uh
four
and and if say is is r is equal to for
example
uh two uh then the the the geithmann
basic local sentence is satisfied but
your algorithm would not find them
uh because both the blue x1 and blue x2
were excluded
uh once we have fixed the red x1 so this
is an example of how you can get a false
negative in the algorithm but if you
think about it the only way you can get
a false negative in in the algorithm is
if both the blue x1 and x blue x2
are close to the red x1 so in fact
the only way you can get the first
negative is that the basic local
sentence is
satisfied by some pair of vertices which
is at a distance at most 2r
because well by the triangle inequality
from blue x1 to red x1 there's distance
at most r from red x1 to blue x2 there's
distance at most r and therefore from
blue x1 to blue x2 there's distance at
most 2r
and therefore uh force negatives are
witnessed by uh
by the fact that there are two vertices
which are close to each other and
such pairs can be found in linear time
in the bounded degree
graphs because you just have to inspect
neighborhoods of size
at most to air to r and and these have
constant size
this is how you solve it for k equals
two and for k equals
three or bigger you use a variation of
the idea so it's a
uh it's a greedy algorithm augmented
with
inspection of of larger neighborhoods
than just r
uh but i won't give the details of of
that you you can
either figure it out yourself or look up
the paper
so this is cess's theorem so on graphs
of bounded
for every bound on the degree you can
evaluate
sentences of first order logic in linear
time
or although the complexity of this
algorithm is first of all there's the
cost of
finding converting a formula to a
geiffman
local form which is a non-elementary
and then or there's also the exponential
size blow up when you look at
neighborhoods of some fixed uh radius r
uh now uh cesar's algorithm is just one
of a family of
uh of of results of of this type and and
and they go quite far and it's a it's a
fascinating story
and let me describe to you uh two
important
ways in which says theorem can be
generalized
so one of them says that you can do what
cesar did
not only for graphs of bounded degree
but for any class of graphs which
is sparse in a certain sense which is
called
nowhere dense and i will describe it in
a moment and then there is
another story which is a a graph measure
called
twin wheels which is a very recent and
i'd also like to uh discuss that
direction as well
so let me begin with nowhere dense
classes so consider
any of the following graph classes
graphs of degree at most five this is an
example of a graph a graph class of
bounded degree
graphs of truth at most five
is a class of bounded truth so
by says a theorem you can evaluate first
order logic on graphs of degree at most
five and linear
time and by corsair's theorem you can
evaluate not only first order logic but
also monadic second order logic
on graphs of trees at most five you can
also
evaluate a first order logic on a planar
graph in linear
time and you can do that as well
for graphs that avoid say the five click
as a graph minor
and these are these are all
later results so for all of these
classes
each of these classes uh there is a
linear time algorithm
which inputs a graph from the class and
tells you if it
if if the graph such says the formula
file and as usual
the linearities in terms of the input
graph but not in terms
of the formula and uh there is actually
a uniform
these are all the results that were
proved separately but there is a uniform
explanation which is a
very beautiful and which is a captured
by the notion of a nowhere dense
craft class so and nowhere dense
is a property of a class of graphs so
that it's a it's a third order
uh notion because it is a set of sets of
graphs so what is a nowhere
dense class so let me explain the
definition at least
so let me define a nowhere dense nowhere
density of a graph class
it's the consider a radius r
it's similar to the radius in geisman
normal form and
let's define a minor relation which is
parametrized by the radius so let's have
say i have a smaller graph h
and i have say a bigger graph g and i
say that
h is an r minor of the bigger graph
g if you can associate to each
vertex of eight a subset of vertex is
vertices in g
so here h has four vertices so i
i associated uh four subsets of vertices
in the following way first of all uh our
subsets are pairwise disjoint
and they have radius r so it means that
for each subset you can
pick a point in the subset such that all
other vertices in the subset are at
distance at most are from from the
central point
and the second property is that you can
recover the if you simulate
the vertices of h by the corresponding
subsets in g you can
you can recover the edges so if you have
two vertices in edge which are connected
by an
edge then the corresponding subsets
are also connected by an edge so in the
example that i gave to you
you can see that in h is a clique so
every vertex is connected to each other
and if you look at the red subsets
in g they also form a clique in the
sense that for every two
red subsets you can find an edge which
has one point
end point in one of the subsets and
another endpoint in the other sub so
this way we have shown that the red
subsets demonstrate
uh the air graph h as a minus and the
radius r
is well the the the radius of these
of all of these substances in this case
one because
for each of the subsets you can find a
uh
a vertex such that all of the other
vertices are a distance at most one
so here we have shown that the red
example graph h is a one
minor of g but of course you could have
a two minor three minor and so on
so the classical notion of graph minor
is just an r minor for some r
but it turns out to be quite fruitful to
introduce this parameter so here's the
definition of nowhere denseness which is
due to necessitas it says that a class
of graph c
is nowhere dense if for radi every
radius r
you cannot get all graphs as r minus so
as you increase the radius you get more
and more
minors and every minor
in the usual graph minor sense is an r
minor for some r
but what the definition says is that
uh you uh uh well at any finite state of
r you will never get all
graphs so let's have a look at uh at
some examples
uh by the way a word uh just to to to to
uh to to make it clear we're talking
about finite graphs here
for example if you take a graph a class
of graph which has bounded degree
then it is nowhere dense and why is that
because if you take an
r minor of a graph which has degree at
most d
then it's easy to see that uh the minor
will have degree at most d to the power
of r plus one because uh
the the vertices will be uh balls of
radius
r and uh such a ball of radius r can
have at most
r plus one uh vertices
and therefore when the
radius r of the minor is fixed you will
only get graphs of bounded degree and
therefore you will not get for example
a large cliques example two suppose that
a class has bounded true
then it also is nowhere dense and and
and here the reasons as follows
uh it is if you take a graph of say of
true k
then it cannot have a k plus one clique
and also there's the grid are another
example but let's stay with clicks
it cannot have a k plus one click as a
minor for any r
so in fact here there's a stronger
property which is
that there is exists a a graph
which cannot be obtained as a minor for
for all r in other words it's an
excluded uh
minor class and so every excluded minor
class is going to be nowhere down
so nowhere dance class classes graph
classes
include bounded tree with they include
bounded degree they also include
all bounded excluded minor classes
such as planar graphs for example and
and therefore all of the
graph classes which are listed here are
examples of nowhere dense classes
now let's see how we can leverage the
fact that uh classes uh nowhere dense
well here's an important result which
says that if a class of graphs is
nowhere dense then model checking for
every fixed formula a first order
formula
is linear time almost linear time so it
says
that if you have a nowhere dense graph
class then for a first every first order
sentence
uh the moral checking problem can be
solved in well it's not exactly linear
time but
it's n to the power one plus epsilon for
an epsilon
which can be made arbitrarily small so
this is a
i will not have time to uh discuss
the proof of this theorem uh
but i just want to uh mention that it it
uses well apart from the geifement
theorem of course
it uses the the the theory of nowhere
dance
graph classes which is very well
developed
initially by uh mendez who proved
many equivalent characterizations and
one of the
important uh notions that appears there
is a tree depth so
it turns out that there's a connection
between lower denseness and then tree
depth which is a
and three deficient is a notion that
it's connected well it's
similar to true but slightly different
all i want to say is that this is a
fascinating story and i
i i encourage you to have a look at at
these results if if you have time
the result is optimal in the sense that
if you take a class which is not nowhere
dense
then model checking is hard so here i
assume that
the class is closed under subgraphs now
by subgroup i mean not induced subgraphs
but
graphs which can be obtained by
eliminating vertices and or edges
uh note that if a class is nowhere dense
then if you close it under subgraphs
then it continues to be
nowhere dense so the groyer creator and
zebras algorithm
it works the interesting cases
classes which are closed under subgraphs
and let me observe now that if a class
is closed under subgraph and it is not
nowhere dense
then model checking is going to be hard
so why is that well suppose that the
class is not
nowhere dense and close under subclass
then if you unfold the definition of
being not nowhere tense it means that
there is some
radius r uh there's some radius where
you can get
all graphs as minors using that radius
and then uh you can show that the
following is well almost true it's not
literally true to to make it true you
have to
have a slightly more technical
definition but
it is true enough so that you can get
the picture
the following is almost true that for
every graph you can see its r
subdivision as an element of the class c
and an r subdivision of a graph is a
graph which is obtained by replacing
paths edges by paths of length
r and as i said it's not literally true
but it's
it is close enough and if you have a
class
which contains our subdivisions say five
subdivisions of all graphs
then the model checking for that uh
graph class is going to be as hard as as
as
the model checking problem for all
graphs because you can use first order
logic to
to to replace a path of length with
edges
and then you can simulate every graph in
in that class
so this is just a proof sketch but it's
not hard to get the actual proof
which says that if a class is not
nowhere dense and closed under subgraphs
then model checking is hard so for graph
classes we know exactly when a model
checking
is it can be done efficiently for a
fixed formula
if the class graph the graph class is
nowhere dense
then it is almost linear and uh that i
had there's a diatomy so otherwise if it
is not nowhere dense
then it is as hard as the general
problem and then therefore conjectured
uh to be impossible to do with a
polynomial fixed degree this is all
under the assumption that we're working
with
graphs classes closed under subglass
which is actually going to be a an
important
which is going to be the motivation uh
for the next
and last topic of my tutorial which is
twin width
so first order logic is
is linear time on some
graph classes which have which are not
nowhere dense
but they're not closed under subgraphs
here's some examples
suppose that you take uh planar graphs
and then you complement them in the
sense that
for every edge you replace it by a
non-edge and for every
known that you replace it by an edge so
you just in terms of first order logic
instead of edge you you you take the
negation of edges
now since a complement
for first order logic it doesn't matter
if there is an a
if you have to write edge or you have to
write non-edge then
complements of planar graphs are just as
hard as planar graphs and planar graphs
are
nowhere dense another example is you can
take complements of graphs of street or
smokes five or just
generally any uh you take any class
say nowhere dense you take the
complements of those graphs and then you
will get
a class of graphs which has uh
uh linear time or almost linear time
model checking and
these graph classes are not closed under
subgraphs well the the examples of
complements are closed under adding
vertices
they're closed under adding edges but
they're not closed under supplies
another example is if you're familiar
with clique then you take
any class of glass of bounded clique
with and then
even mso as long as you're not allowed
to quantify over sets of
edges only sets of vertices any such a
class of bounded clique with is going to
have
a first first order and even mso model
checking
in linear time uh so these are classes
which are not nowhere dense but they're
not closed under subgraphs and it would
be nice to have a theory
which explains uh why
a model checking is efficient for
such a graph classes well the first two
examples you could say is just a nowhere
dense hiding behind complement but the
click width is not like that
and then you can
hide the complement even further so that
it's a it's
not clearly visible and it would be nice
to have a theory which explains this
and there is a a a recent development in
in in group graph theory and
and logical applications which
which can be seen as giving a uniform
explanation of some of these
for all of these graph classes which is
something called a bounded twin
so let me explain what this is
consider a graph and a partition with a
partition of its vertices into some
blocks
so say here we have partitioned the the
graph itself has
eight vertices and we partitioned them
into three blocks abc
and i would say that uh two blocks are
consistent
if they are connected in the same way so
what does that mean so for example
blocks a and b
are consistent because for every vertex
from a
and for every vertex from b there is an
edge between them so it doesn't
matter which vertex you choose from a
which vertex you choose from b
there's always going to be an edge and
well dually
blocks b and c are also consistent uh
because uh
there is for every vertex pair one from
b one from c
there is a non-edge between them on the
other hand blocks a and c are
inconsistent because
uh sometimes there is an edge and
sometimes there's not an edge it depends
on how you choose the vertex from a and
how you choose
a vertex from c so this is
this this notion can be used to define
twin width as follows
it's a notion which was a it's a very
recent notion as you can see
a graph has a twin with a k and the k is
is a number it's like protrude if you
can
find the sequence of partitions on its
vertices with the following property
so first of all you start out with the
trivial partition where every vertex is
its norm
in its own block and then you end up in
a in the partition where everybody is
is together and then when you go
from one partition to the next one you
just merge
two blocks and uh the
most important property is that at any
given moment
when you have a partition for every
block there is a
constant number well k blocks
which are inconsistent with it so
if you look at the inconsistency graph
then it has a degree at most
k so the idea is that you well
in the first stage p1 it is a
the blocks are trivial then it's going
to be
consistent for trivial reasons and then
but as you start emerging vertices you
could
create some inconsistencies as a result
of that
but what you're what you have to have
what you need to keep
is that at any given moment there is a
bounded number of inconsistencies for
every every block
and this is the notion of twin bits
let's have a look at some examples
first let's look at clips i claim that
every click width has twin with
zero so why is that well here's a click
say a six click
and uh let's give a a twin with
decomposition it's going to be quite
trivial
so i begin as i have to with every
vertex being genome partition
and there are no inconsistencies here
because where
you cannot have inconsistencies since
inconsistencies
every block at size one but then i
joined the first two uh
uh blocks now since it's a clique so
every two subsets are going to be
completely uh
consistent are going to be consistent uh
and therefore there are zero
inconsistencies here and there in
particular every block is
is inconsistent with zero other blocks
and therefore i can just keep on joining
from left to right all the vertices
and and this way i see that the the
creek has twin with
zero note that for example uh i could
remove for example one edge from the the
creek
and it would have a twin width one
because there would be at most one
inconsistency between
blocks along at every step
along the way another observation is
that
if a graph has a twin width k then if
you take the complement of the graph so
you replace edges by
non-edges and vice versa then you the
same
uh sequence of partitions will have the
same kinds of inconsistencies
and and therefore it will be also a
witness for a twin width
okay so it's it's it's a measure of
graph that's stable
under taking complements and as i've
observed it before it's also
well stable under uh removing individual
edges
by stable i mean that it's uh
it does not change too much and uh what
he
actually can prove this was is that uh
this is a a stronger than clique in the
sense that uh
uh having
the three measures uh that i have
discussed in this
in this talk well uh tree width and twin
with five
defined liquid by only mentioned in
passing they are related by implications
in the sense that it
bounded through it implies clique with
and the witness for the difference is is
is say click clicks uh and then bounded
uh
liquid implies a bounded uh
twin width and uh because you can it's
it's not so hard to replace a
disc position if you know by it by
a twin with uh decomposition of of
of similar width and again the
implication is strict because for
example the classical
planar graphs it has bounded between
with
namely i think four or three and and
planar graphs can have a unboundedly
high
uh liquid so uh
in this sense a twin with is a far
reaching a generalization of of of tree
with ven
and clean a new result
that that was proved well together with
wynwood says that the first order
uh uh model checking is is is
is linear time on graphs of a bounded
twin width
so if you're given a graph but
importantly here
you need to uh be given uh the
witness for the with the smart
so the decomposition which is the
witnessing sequence of partitions
but if you're given a graph together uh
with
a witnessing sequence of partitions and
you can evaluate a
first order formula in in linear time uh
using uh well
guys man-like techniques but of course
uh you need to understand twin
quite well for that uh it would be nice
to have a say a linear or maybe cubic
algorithm which would compute the
witnessing sequence of partitions or
something like the bod lambda theorem
uh for bounded twin width but as far as
i know this has not been
achieved yet uh and and here we have uh
so
so summing up there exists uh many
restrictions on
graph classes which ensure that the
first order can be
load formula fixed first order formulas
can be evaluated efficiently
and in most cases it's actually a linear
or almost
linear time so the examples i gave are
nowhere that's in twin roots maybe
i would like to point out that these two
are incomparable so
uh well clicks uh i have bounded
treatment when we defend
and are not nowhere ends but conversely
for example a bounded degree
graph boundary degree does not apply
about the twin width and uh this
sums up this part of the of my talk
which is actually the last part uh which
says that for
uh you can evaluate first order logic
efficiently
and uh uh and so we come to the end of
my talk
about algorithmic metatheorems which say
that any
algorithmic problem that you can
formalize in logic you can solve it
efficiently well assuming that the logic
is right and the class of
models or graphs that you care about is
right
and so we come to the end of the entire
tutorial
and i hope that it has been a bit useful
for for you
thank you very much